t.i apparently approached a uh
a comedian for making jokes about him ah
this is true
it was that are we uh
it was an open mic are we open mic
in it yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
i actually spoke to the girl and i spoke
to ti this morning uh separately but
like uh and it was interesting
so i don't know if you guys saw the
video do we want to play a little bit of
it what do you guys think i could pull
it up we also got to get ti on the pod
eventually yeah yeah for sure right here
um
bump it
so what's happening is there's an open
mic um
what happened beforehand is
i'll do a little setup i guess what
happened forehand is that he came in to
pop into the mic he did some time
uh he got off she starts making fun of
him he makes fun of her
hair in the uh
her hair in like the hat
and she responds with you you got to
talk about those allegations
so then he goes nah we're not going to
talk about that right now and then
to charge me for
everybody
shut the [ __ ] up for a second
hey listen
go go
[Music]
the back story is they had like a little
kind of beef or whatever i think
even before this he thought that they
squash it that's why he came to her mic
was doing some time maybe he did a
longer amount of time then the back and
forth about the hat happened and then
t.i is like
you know what do i what i do i just let
people say these things and you know
basically i was telling him i was like
listen as a comedian you can't really
tell people they're not allowed to joke
about you because you're just going to
make them want to joke about you even
100
and i also understand this girl it's
like
you know one coming from a place where
like someone's silencing her on her
stage especially like a comic and saying
you can't make these jokes yeah you know
it's
yeah it's it's [ __ ] sucks dude it
[ __ ] sucks but i told him i was like
dude you don't want to be the guy that
says you can't joke around about me
because then all comics are going to
want to joke around about you and
they're not going to look at you as a
real comic 100
but i also understand him it's like what
do i just let the world call me a
[ __ ] sexual predator or whatever
but you also got to keep perspective on
like this is an open mic or whatever
this is like a small show yeah it's not
like this is gonna you made it go viral
by acting like this it would have just
died right there yep you kind of got to
let it sit and that's the thing comics
sit on a high horse a lot and talk [ __ ]
and act like we got no skeletons but
with a guy that's already famous the
skeletons are out yeah so it's tough
it's a tricky thing but that's also
something he got to recognize coming
into the game yeah like
like if you come in if you go to a rap
battle for example and you're talking
[ __ ] about someone please believe
they're going to bring up yep
you're you're crazy as [ __ ] yep so
these are the costs of coming to the
game and going back and forth with
somebody you might never know they might
drop some crazy [ __ ] yeah you you can't
not expect that yeah yeah it's like it's
like you don't get to do
everything on your own terms in life
yeah and that's the tricky thing that
he's in right now
yeah but i empathize for it's like
imagine every time you say anything they
just bring up some [ __ ] that has no
bearing no case no nothing yeah it just
taints who you are in your legacy when
there's no proof it's on the courts
like yeah what is the status of that
because last i heard it was like
allegations were brought up and then i
think it got wiped away
so there's not even any charge made so
it's like
it's one thing if it's in the courts
yeah but it's nothing if it's not and
there's no charges and it just goes away
and it was like oh people trying to like
me to him on some fake [ __ ] but
everybody's acting as if it's real i
could i could empathize with how
frustrating that is yeah but i also
empathize with the comics like yo you're
not gonna tell me what i can or can't
joke about no [ __ ] chance you coming
in here to do the comedy show especially
my show
what i can't do nah not gonna happen
[ __ ] that yeah and that's what i told
her so it's a it's a tricky but that's
the issue is you make a scene about it
and then all of a sudden way more people
see it's like the streisand effect like
by trying to block it and trying to
close it out it makes it bigger yeah i
don't know what what are you guys
thoughts i mean like ideally you
like just kind of take it and then it
eventually gets washed away yeah you
know i mean like eventually it just gets
caught out like i didn't know really
about the allegations until this video
i i didn't know either and that's the
thing like he might not realize he's
going to put more sauce on these things
100 you just let it [ __ ] go you made
it mainstream with this but this will
eventually wash away too
like if you just don't bring this up
like just be cool for a while like this
will go away and then the rest will go
but you're gonna have to eat some [ __ ]
in the meantime you're gonna have to
deal with a lot of people making jokes
about it now and you gotta kind of know
that's if i wanna keep doing comedy this
is what's gonna happen i did that to me
and this is a learning lesson and then
in a few years hopefully people stop
doing that [ __ ] yeah especially if you
laugh at it assuming it's all untrue
which she's claiming like the whole
thing's [ __ ] and there's no like
legitimate charge in the courts yeah and
another thing that happened later in the
video is like he goes on stage and and
like takes the mic from her yeah which
is you can't and he doesn't he's not
he's like hugging her first and then he
just rips the mic but it's like
nah bruh you can't do that you can't go
up with two comedians you can't put you
can't
touch him and you definitely can't
remove microphones from convenience
especially you come in as a comedian
yeah but i i understand he's coming from
the rap game where it's like fighting
for your identity and your persona and
your narrative is everything yeah
someone talks [ __ ] about you you got to
come back with a song yeah yeah yeah so
he's applying that to the comedy game
you come back with jokes yeah
in this game and he runs with dc in them
so he knows like
[ __ ] that you can go yeah you get if you
get that muscle up and just go go go you
can win yeah this combination of rappers
comedians women's hair weird sex [ __ ]
it just makes her a bad combination bro
yo it's so true but right back in square
one yeah yeah
but yeah if i'm him i just handle this
off stage
go up to her afterwards just be like yo
you gotta stop saying [ __ ] that's not
true blah blah and just like handle it
with her like one maybe you don't see
how you gotta
just say hey man it's just that's
something really
hard for me like we're gonna see each
other we're both in the comedy scene
here we're gonna try to do this comics
like
i don't get why you're coming to me yeah
like on on this [ __ ] i get we're scoring
you also got to say that because he
started it so i get we're scoring but
like that's kind of a low blow because
that [ __ ] isn't true i understand if
that triggers you in some way but you
gotta understand i'm actually innocent i
know a lot of guys say that and then
whatever and then hopefully she believes
you and then you can squash it but if
you handle it like that you have a much
higher chance of squashing it than you
do if you go up and grab the [ __ ]
microphone yeah and then the video is
out on elon musk's twitter and yeah it's
over dude
you